أريد أن أخذكم الآن مباشرة إلى غزة
ومعتز عزة صحفي ومصور فلسطيني
أم، من الرائع أن أتحدث
إليكم أه إسرائيل تقول إنها تستهدف حماس
بالطبع بعد أهوال 7 أكتوبر
أنها تتجنب سقوط ضحايا من المدنيين
أنت هناك كل يوم توثق
ماذا يحدث ماذا ترى هل تشعر أن
إسرائيل تحاول تجنب
سقوط ضحايا من المدنيين أه شكرا لاستضافتي أه
صباح الخير أو مساء الخير في
وقتكم أه بالنسبة لي مما أرى لا هم ليسوا ليسوا
أو هم  لا أهتم
بحياة المدنيين إذا كانوا
يستهدفون شخصًا ما أو كان هناك شخص
يريد ذلك لهم حتى لو كان هناك
ألف شخص في نفس
المبنى وهم بحاجة إلى مثل هذا وهناك
شخص مطلوب لهم فسوف يقتلون
الألف قبل أن يقتلوا لذلك  ما يقرب من
10% من جميع الصحفيين المسجلين في
غزة قُتلوا وفقًا
للإحصاءات الرسمية، واحد من كل 10
تقول إسرائيل إنها لا تستهدف الصحفيين أبدًا. ما هو
رأيك، على الرغم من أنك كشخص
يعمل هناك، هل تعتقد أو تشعر أن
الصحفيين مستهدفون بدلاً
من كونهم في غزة؟  مكان خاطئ في
وقت خاطئ أه أولا نحن لسنا
صحفيين دوليين لذلك أه نحن
من أهل غزة نحن سكان غزة
نحن فلسطينيون أه فالخطر على كل أه
قطاع غزة فكلما
استهدفوا مكانا ونذهب  للتغطية أو
عندما نكون في مكان وهم
ذاهبون إلى الهدف لا نعرف أه
فيقتل بعض الصحفيين
وتعرف إسرائيل أن هناك مجلة هناك
لأن طائراتهم بدون طيار في كل السماء
أه وفي كل وقت  اليوم حتى
يعرفوا أن هناك كريم هنا لكنهم
لا يهتمون بحياتنا ح هناك
الكثير منكم
حصلت على هام
ابن مراسل
الجزير ومصطفى وهم أصدقاء مقربين
لي اه نحن زملاء وهم
حصلت على الهدف على سيارتهم لقد
استهدفت الطائرة الإسرائيلية بدون طيار سيارتهم كما هو الحال مع الكثير من
زملائي الكثير منهم أه إذا
سأستمر في ذكر أسمائهم لأنني
أعرف أنني أعرفهم جميعًا بسبب عملي
في السنوات الماضية في الـ G و  كما
تعلم G هي منطقة صغيرة أه حيث
يعرف
الجميع مثل الجميع حسابك على Instagram
وقد يتفاجأ الكثير من الأشخاص بأن
حسابك على Instagram يحتوي على 18 مليون
متابع ما مدى حجم المسؤولية
التي تشعر بها في إظهار ما
يحدث في غزة للعالم  خاصة مع وجود عدد أقل
وأقل من الصحفيين لتغطية
الأمر أه أولاً كان لدي
24000 متابع فقط في اليوم الأول من أه
هذه
الحرب أه ثم آه الناس يتابعونني
لأنني أعرض حقائق RO
بدون أي تعديلات بدون أي تأثيرات
بدون  حتى المؤثرات الصوتية أه أنا
بعملها زي الناس اللي عايشة اللحظة
التي أعيشها معي لذلك أنا قريب جدا من
قلوب الناس عبر هذا أه في
الأيام الأولى كان هناك مسئولية علي
أن على كتفي لإظهارها
الناس ما يحدث ولكن بعد ولكن
بعد ما مررت به في
الأشهر الثلاثة الماضية ونحن
قريبون جدًا من أن نكون مثل 100 يوم من هذه الحرب
وأنا بدأت أفقد الأمل أه بدأت
أفقد كما لو كان الأمر كذلك  إنها ليست
مسؤوليتي بعد الآن لأنني
أظهرت
ما هي اللقطات للناس، إنها
المرة الأولى بالنسبة لهم لرؤيتها
ليشهدوا هذه الحياة وأعذروني، أنا
أؤمن بالناس ولكن أه ماذا مما
رأيته لا يمكنهم التأثير عليه
حكوماتهم لوقف هذا، لذلك فقدت الأمل
في هذا الأمر، فمن الصعب
تصديق أنك تبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا فقط
وأن العمل الذي تقوم به يشاهده
الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يقومون بتوثيق كل
هذا على الرغم من  الدمار الدمار
الوفيات آه الناس
يتضورون جوعًا للحصول على الطعام، لا بد أنه أمر مرهق، فما الذي
يجعلك تستمر، ما الذي
يجعلك مصممًا على الاستمرار بدلاً
من الاحتماء في مكان ما وتكون
آمنًا قدر الإمكان
آه أولاً لجميع الأشخاص الذين
يشاهدون الآن هناك  لا يوجد ملاجئ في غزة
أه إسرائيل تدعي أن أه الناس يحبون الذهاب
إلى الجنوب حتى تكون محميًا لا
أحد محمي نعم يطلبون من الناس
الذهاب إلى الجنوب ويقصفون أكثر في
الجنوب لذلك أه عمري 24 عامًا ماذا
يجعلني أستمر أه أولا هو حب
غزة غزة مكان جميل جدا
وفيها أجمل شاطئ في
العالم كله أه نحب قطاعنا وأه
نتمنى دولة حرة بلد حر
يمكننا أن نعيش حياتنا كمواطنين
أشخاص عاديون كما هو الحال في جميع أنحاء العالم، فما الذي
يجعلني أستمر في ذلك تمامًا مثل أه
حب مكاني ولأنني كنت
أعيش هنا منذ البداية في هذه الحياة
أه أحتاج مثل ما أريد رؤيته مرة أخرى
جميلًا غير
مشتت اه بالنسبة لي أنا'  أنا مثل
الناس حتى أنني لا أستطيع الاستمرار في التصوير
كل يوم، هناك بعض الأيام
أحاول العثور على طعام لعائلتي للأشخاص
الموجودين في
منزلي آه
أحاول العثور على الديزل  حتى أتمكن من
الاستمرار في التحرك لذلك أفقد الكثير من الوقت في
العثور على الأشياء من أجلي حتى أتمكن من
الاستمرار، لذا فهذا أمر خطير ولكن
آه أنا واضح حتى أنا أظهر أنني أظهر ما
لدي لأي شخص لأنه إذا  استهدفتني إسرائيل
لأنني كنت على مسافة قريبة جدًا
من منزلي بحوالي 600 متر، أه
الدبابات والقناصة الإسرائيليين لا أستطيع حتى
الوصول إلى نهاية منزلي لأن
هناك قناصًا يطلق النار على أي شخص على
الطريق الرئيسي الذي أعيش بالقرب منه  الطريق الرئيسي
في المنطقة الوسطى، لذا أه أنا أعرض
حياة موقعي حتى للإسرائيليين
وحتى للأشخاص الذين يتابعونني، لذلك إذا
حدث شيء ما، فيجب أن تعلم أنهم
يعرفون موقعي بالفعل وهم
آسفون لأنك أنت  رجل شجاع للغاية،
الملايين من الناس يرون عملك أه
كل يوم أم م زا، شكرًا جزيلاً لك على
الوقت الذي أمضيته، شكرًا
لك